das ist zurzeit so was wie flüssiges
gold reiner alkohol und
desinfektionsmittel herzustellen
deshalb macht edgardo zu niger nun fast
tag und nacht an seiner destille in
washington dc
heute nacht ist der behälter voll und
dann fließt das dorthin für die zweite
destination eigentlich brennt herum und
whiskey nun macht er fast nur noch hand
desinfektionsmittel
er hat seine gesamte produktion
umgestellt von schnaps aus fässern zu
kein bekämpfer in plastikflaschen
die nachfrage ist riesig die größte
herausforderung gerade ist
plastikflaschen zu finden kleine
flaschen zu bekommen ist sehr schwer
heute fahre ich noch nach baltimore um
10.000 flaschen abzuholen
seit die regale im supermarkt leer sind
steht das telefon hier nicht mehr
stellen das corona virus verbreitet sich
schneller als die großen hersteller
nachliefern können kleine destillerien
wie edgar duss versuchen nun in ihren
gemeinden zu helfen
wir sind nicht losgerannt und haben hand
desinfektionsmittel gehamstert und nach
zwei wochen hatten wir fast nichts mehr
danke also an diese jungs
ich arbeite in einer personalabteilung
und da unser betrieb weiterläuft brauche
ich desinfektionsmittel für meine
mitarbeiter
zwei flaschen pro personen darf jeder
kaufen
mehr nicht was steckt drin in den
fläschchen die jeder haben will kräuter
öle glycerin vitamin d und natürlich
alkohol vier tage am stück 16 stunden
pro tag hat edgardo experimentiert bis
er die perfekte mischung hatte ein
schnapsbrenner der nun gegen viren
kämpft
ich bin im moment wohl die einzige
person die keine angst vor keimen hat
normalerweise verkauft edgardo seine
spirituosen vor allem auch auf märkten
das geht nun nicht mehr sein
eigentliches geschäft am boden
ob das desinfektionsmittel ihn über
wasser halten kann ist unwahrscheinlich
der gewinn einfach zu gering dass hier
also ein ganzer stolz
das ist der proberaum man gleichzeitig
die bahn jetzt die desinfektions
produktion was edgardo freut dass er mit
den kleinen flaschen aktuell vielen
hilft sich vor dem virus zu schützen was
er kaum erträgt den geruch übel riecht
wie brot aus einer bäckerei am anfang
und dann der alkohol und das aroma wenn
du ein bisschen was auf die hände gibst
dann riechst du das getreide
es riecht sehr gut rum genauso aber
jetzt ist es einfach nur pures ethanol
das ist so stark 2000 flaschen hatten
sie für heute produziert das ist alles
was noch übrig ist
die korona krise zwingt alle sich
umzustellen
manche müssen dafür auch träumen
loslassen wir haben jetzt eine bar mit
der wir kein geld machen können
zumindest momentan das ist traurig
wir haben hier viel geld reingesteckt
wenn ich gewusst hätte dass so etwas
passiert hätte ich hier keinen cent
investiert und hier einfach nur verein
gestellt doch für solche gedanken bleibt
keine zeit
dieses telefon hört nicht auf zu
klingeln
guten tag wenn valley distillery wie
kann ich ihnen helfen
sie bekommen anfragen aus dem ganzen
land wollen aber vor ort helfen ja für
anwohner haben wir noch hand
desinfektionsmittel und die kommen bis
zum ladenschluss um 16 uhr edgar dass
mitarbeiter david und george sind froh
sie haben zu tun
und doch fehlt ihnen ihr altes leben ich
vermisse es mich mit den kunden wirklich
auszutauschen und ihre geschichten zu
hören über unsere produkte oder einfach
übers leben
man stand in verbindung und das vermisse
ich
ich vermisse meine bar
ich will sie zurück ich vermisse diesen
ort wirklich ich habe dort erst vor zwei
monaten angefangen haben stetig
fortschritte gemacht und waren gerade
dabei uns auf frühling und sommer
vorzubereiten
jetzt nehmen wir es tag für tag
es ist nicht einfach aber wir können ja
nichts daran ändern
irgendwann so hoffen sie machen sie hier
wieder was was richtig gut riecht